at this point there is over 50 years
worth of Doctor Who where do you start
as someone who very obviously really
loves Doctor Who a question I will
sometimes get from people who know me
and have heard great things about the
show but I've never watched it before is
well where do I begin and that's really
a kind of a tough question to answer but
I'll start with what you don't do what
you don't do is go back to the first
episodes from 1963 and try and start
there there's a number of reasons you
don't do that aside from the fact that
it would take forever the big thing is
though I really don't think the classic
error is where any modern audience
should be starting you can enjoy the
classic era certainly but I think you're
gonna be better off starting with the
modern era get hooked into it first come
to like the character like the world and
then go back watch the older stuff the
older stuff it's very of its time it's
very dated in a lot of ways and it's
very held back by the budgetary
restrictions of the time there's still
some fantastic stuff from the classic
era but I don't think it's a good hook
or a good starting place for people
trying to get into this for the first
time again once you're into the show by
all means go back and watch it don't
feel obligated to watch classic era
stuff in chronological order though
because they're pretty much all
self-contained stories you can watch
them in any order you feel like but you
really you need to start somewhere on
the modern era which started in 2005
with Christopher Eccleston as the ninth
doctor now logically wouldn't you just
say so you start with the 2005 so with
series 1 then right no I'm not sure I'd
recommend that either the thing is is
that that first series I don't really
feel is particularly good representation
of the show at this point there was a
lot of stuff that went on in that first
series that got dropped a lot of goofy
aspects a lot of sort of more juvenile
more child as touches that got dropped
and really almost immediately by the
next series they've gotten rid of a lot
of that stuff so I'm not sure that
that's the best place to start either
and the other thing is even if you start
that that's still over ten years of
stuff that you've got to catch up on
from that which that can be a bit of a
chore so here's what I tend to recommend
to people thinking about getting into
Doctor Who for the first time my
recommendations are twofold I have a
test
episode and then I actually have a place
where I recommend that they start my
test episode is blink I will tell people
okay you've never seen Doctor Who go see
the episode blink just that episode
because I think blink is the episode
where you can go in knowing nothing
about the character nothing about the
premise nothing about anything you can
watch it you can follow that story you
can get what's going on you can get a
feel of the character you can get a feel
of the type of stories that get told you
can get a feel of what people love about
this show now if you watch blink and it
doesn't grab you and you're not left
going I want to see more stuff like this
you know what just walk away the shows
not for you and that's fine but if it
does intrigued you my own recommendation
for where to start after that is with
the eleventh hour which is Matt Smith's
first episode now I'm sure some people
who follow this channel are gonna be
saying well you're just saying that
because Matt Smith's your favorite
doctor and I'm not gonna say that's not
part of the reason I'm sure it probably
is but it's an option I kinda came to
really by process of elimination as I
said the start of series one the it's
just not indicative of the rest of the
show now maybe starting series two with
David Tennant that's an option I the
thing is though Christmas invasion which
this is first episode still it has a
little bit of the lingering goofiness
from series one and then the actual
proper start of series two with new
earth and then tooth and claw and some
other stuff it's there's a lot of stuff
I love in series two the way that it
starts isn't great and there's some
really rough episodes in that season
that's the season that I had fear her
and love and monsters so I'm not sure
that that's a series to recommend people
start with if you're trying to get them
to fall in love with the show starting
in series three receivers four could
work but by that point we're getting too
many callbacks on references to stuff
that had already gone on the show and
people are gonna know that they're
missing out on stuff now are there
callbacks at the start of Matt Smith's
era which was series 5 yes there are but
really that first episode especially the
11th hour really was designed as a
jumping on point and you get the doctor
and you get a new companion you get a
summary of how he works how the TARDIS
works how his life works and when Steven
Moffat who became the showrunner at the
start of that series took over he didn't
I'm not gonna say he didn't call back to
the stuff that had gone on before them
but it was more referential it didn't
dig deeply into what had gone on before
so the start of series 5 really does
work as AI has a very good starting
point now I suppose the other
possibility to consider would be deep
breath the start of series 8 which was
Peter Capaldi who at the time of this
recording is the current doctor but
again I don't feel that that episode
works particularly well as a jumping on
point the other thing as much as I
personally loved Capaldi's doctor he's a
big bristle ease a bit prickly
especially in his first series and I'm
not sure that he's gonna be as a pible
and as good at pulling in new people as
Matt Smith was who was just lovable and
warm and I I think he works a lot better
in terms of hooking people and again yes
I will admit he is my favorite doctor
but you have to admit the guy's just
kind of more welcoming just as a persona
as a personality so anyway that's my own
recommendation for what I tell people
where do you start
with Doctor Who now if you're a Doctor
Who fan you've gone all the way through
this video what starting point would you
recommend for people trying to get into
this show for the first time whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
please feel free to like subscribe check
out the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned